foreign
successful companies don't invest in
Talent so the competition can hire them
away
they keep their people motivated to grow
with the company
and Inspire those around them to lean in
with them
I believe that Talent retention the same
tool used to grow successful companies
can be used to build great neighborhoods
for the people born and raised in them
my hometown is the South Bronx in New
York City and it's the challah
um and it's the kind of neighborhood
that some might say actually has a
talent repulsion strategy
back in the 1980s I walked by this crack
house on the way to the subway that
would take me to my high school one of
the best in the country the Bronx High
School of Science
all right figured there'd be at least
some of you in here
um neighborhoods like mine are places
where inequality is assumed by the
people who live there and by everyone
else on the outside looking in these are
places where the schools public health
air and water parks and trees food
options
career opportunities are worse than in
other parts of the same town
government subsidized rental housing and
health clinics homeless shelters liquor
stores dollar stores predominate a few
Banks but plenty of check-cashing stores
or pawn shops that charge you to use the
money you may have I refer to these
communities as a low status I don't call
them poor or underprivileged because
frankly status implies something larger
and deeper at work and that inequality
is a well-established fact
think of the communities like that near
you they're everywhere their inner
cities their reservations white Rust
Belt towns and all over the world and
bright kids who grow up in them are
expected to measure success by how far
they get away from them
I was one of those kids and now I'm a
real estate developer and strategy
consultant and I work nationally but the
South Bronx is my research and
development laboratory where for where I
actually practice restorative Community
Development and that same Corner that
was once a crack house is now the home
of my hip-hop Cafe award-winning hip-hop
Cafe the um excuse me the boogie down
grind and it is
and it's two blocks away from the house
I grew up in and around the corner from
where I live right now so I have
embraced my intercapitalist and my inner
socialist and my inner libertarian and
among a bunch of other things however
but I'd like to talk now about how
capitalism and the spirit behind it
and its application that's what
determines its outcomes
so
U.S capitalism supported slavery
and it supported Black Wall Streets
those communities of black folks
formally enslaved are just one
generation out of it and where they
built great builds as businesses and
wealth and communities and the most
famous of which was the town of
Greensville greenswood in Tulsa Oklahoma
Black Wall Streets were destroyed
burned down
and the black people in their Murder by
white mobs savagely and without
consequence
now was that capitalism's fault
or some kind of white cultural flaw
or distinction
that has gone unaddressed to the state
now I know some people don't like
hearing about it but imagine what it
feels like to experience it
I mean America has had a talent
retention strategy or some of something
like it in place since 1619.
slavery provided white Americans with
all the benefits of the that barbaric
and predatory industry and although
Black Wall Streets were built on the
sustainable ideals of life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness and property
ownership Black Wall Streets were
destroyed because the people who built
them were not white
same system
very different outcomes
Citigroup estimates that the racial
wealth Gap that in the U.S has actually
cost us 16 trillion dollars over the
last 20 years alone
now let's just think about that for just
a moment
that the money that could have gone into
the economy but didn't
because of systemic racism that defined
who benefited
from America's growth
there's no need to reinvent the wheel
here
if we want to make America as good as
its promise
then we should apply the same tools of
capitalism that built white wealth
to build wealth in low status
communities especially
especially in terms of of property
ownership and real estate development
because real estate development in low
status communities in the U.S currently
takes one of two paths you know the
first poverty maintenance wherein you'll
see things like
the concentration of things such as
health clinics and government subsidized
housing rent excuse me rental housing
pharmacies philanthropic and government
dollars poor in and the non-profit
industrial complex seems to view poverty
sort of as a an authentic cultural
attribute for the area and thus you'll
see all sorts of programs that are
designed to sort of manage that prop
that poverty but the communities do not
improve money will be made lots of it
but not for the local people and in fact
one can view many of the
well-intentioned programs as Talent
extraction
because the promising Talent is
encouraged to grow up and be somebody
but certainly not in their own hood
and the other type is gentrification
displacement when urban populations grow
even some politicians and even some
activists will resist greater density
um so you have Rising demand and limited
Supply
and then prices go up and gentrification
generally means Outsiders coming into
our community in order to build one
that's like suits their needs and their
desires but and it's not for the needs
and desires or the people that are
already in that Community but let's just
be real it's it's not always mutually
exclusive because people in those
communities want nice things too they do
and that's why they leave whenever they
can in order to experience them so
capitalism can fuel gentrification and
displacement or poverty maintenance but
neither neither of these strategies
actually help the kind of the people in
those communities living the kind of of
neighborhoods that we all deserve
what if we looked at low status
communities as though they were
struggling companies
how would we turn them around
how would a talent retention model work
in out in on a neighborhood scale
so municipalities they hand out
corporate retention deals because they
believe that the economic activity that
it'll produce is actually worth the
subsidy that they pay out and so we'll
need to do the same thing for in low
status communities for the people that
we were led to believe that they need to
measure success by how far they get away
from those places so
well you know we can't really Force
anybody to stay but we can nudge them
with lifestyle infrastructure the type
of stuff that we learn through our own
market research that people told us that
they want it
um places like cafes and bars and
bookstores and farmers markets and you
know the places that frankly you
probably all like to go to too they
build positive Community interactions
and make people feel really cool so
another nudge would be real access to
property ownership and business
ownership that keeps people vested in
their neighborhoods these are like
benefits you know and companies stock
options the kind that so when the
community does well
the so do the resonance it's kind of
like the the employees of a hot startup
so how do we make sure that these
benefits and stock options get in the
right hands and appreciate and value for
them
now in the U.S if you're accused of a
crime and can't afford legal counsel a
public defender will be assigned to you
the same can be done for local Property
Owners before a real estate transaction
goes forward within a low status
Community the seller should receive
quality legal and financial counsel so
they are fully aware of the value of
their land and how they could maximize
it through sensible refinancing by
building you know vertical editions for
rentals and also you know accessory
dwelling units and also using the value
to to do sensible refinancing put their
their kids through college build a
business
um you know or maybe
you know since this is Property Owners
might even be considered a protected
class by the United States a Security
and Exchange Commission in order to
protect black wealth in particular and
other low status Community well from the
continuing liquidation that they still
deal with because it is common for
people who do own property in low status
communities to be approached all the
time uh for for quick cash offers these
are actual solicitations that I've
received at my home
um these can be they can be very
enticing to people who have never been
led to believe that there's any real
value in their community and the thing
is it's all legal
and real estate companies big and small
as well as private Equity have done a
very effective job of increasing wealth
inequality in the U.S
by separating financially unsavvy people
from any hope of generational wealth
potential
so
you know
the SEC recently proposed new rules
requiring businesses to report their
greenhouse gas emissions in an effort to
increase transparency of the risk to and
for its investors maybe they should do
the same thing for taxpayers we know
real estate and private Equity firms can
engage in predatory practices at the
expense of taxpayers by privatizing the
the the the profits and socializing the
costs and this is because a business
model that reduces opportunities for
home ownership also creates more
landless renters exacerbates the
concentration of poverty and
statistically increases poverty's ill
effects including higher rates of bad
policing and incarceration and lower
health and educational outcomes
their message shut out aspiring
homeowners from the American dream
it comes at a cost to all of us and so
it should come at a far greater cost to
those who do business like that
another issue is that some renters
actually pay more in rent than they
would on a mortgage but most of us who
actually need a mortgage cannot compete
with the speed at which predatory
speculators show up with all cash deals
period a possible solution is
fulfillanthropic organizations to buy
properties at market rate and value from
those who actually choose once they're
fully aware of what they're selling who
choose people who choose to sell and
then hold them so that other folks
within the communities have the time
to get financing and then buy that's a
valuable cushion of time for people and
it gives people a chance to participate
in the American dream and it's a low
risk place to park capital
these are some examples of just how we
can build a restorative economic
approach to to capitalism it's still
capitalism but with rules and practices
that favor the outcomes that we need as
an as a nation
but folks on the ground they are not
waiting they're absolutely not waiting
in uh in West Oakland California third
generation West Oakland or Noni session
leaves the East Bay permanent real
estate Cooperative they have recently
acquired property collectively to build
a permanent affordable mixed-use real
estate development that benefits its
resident owners the cooperatives offers
these lunchtime learning sessions so
people can fully understand things about
investment and development and to their
current membership includes about 500
Community investor resident and staff
owners and they have to date raised five
million dollars for their Community
landing and housing fund
in Philadelphia a community development
program started by uh called jumpstart
started by Ken Weinstein
um it's he's a commercial real estate
developer and he provides and the
program provides uh training mentoring
and Loans to aspiring local residential
developers mostly on women and people of
color since 2015 they're they trained
more than 2500 people
um uh more than 350 loans totaling more
than 40 million dollars that have
actually rehabbed more than 350 units
have been re totally rehabilitated
um their respective activities actually
improve the value of each other's
properties and these and they're
reducing blight you know in Philly from
the neighborhood by neighborhood from
the inside out and there now jump Starts
Now in more than 13 communities around
the country
and
June lankert is a member of the IAC
tribe in Alaska and he's what he's
working on is securing
um livelihoods for aspiring native Youth
and women you know up and where he's
from and um he's doing it through kelp
farming in ancestral native Waters kelp
is a traditional food source number one
and it also has important commercial
components in bioplastics and uh um
Pharmaceuticals and also if they use it
as an additive and cow feed to reduce
the methane in it I mean it's it's
amazing and what it could do and so what
he's competing against multinational
companies to actually own a piece of
this emerging ocean industry for his
people so
he's going to be up against it but he's
got to be doing this it's so important
and in the South Bronx there's this
historic rail station that brought my
daddy who was a Pullman Porter into the
neighborhood when I was where I was born
and raised
um back in the 1940s it was even harder
to get a mortgage while black and he won
fifteen thousand dollars in a horse race
and carried it in a satchel you know
back across the country and purchased a
home near that rail station for his
family
and that rail station has recently been
acquired by his baby daughter be me who
is um
transforming it into a mixed you into a
multi-use performance venue an event
hall for music and weddings and
Quinceaneras and gaming tournaments
and I
I am the manifestation of my mommy and
daddy's wildest dreams
now
I'm not saying that Talent retention is
going to solve all the problems
associated with poverty maintenance or
displacement and gentrification or solve
all the wrongs of capitalism
but I know we are not going to solve
any
of those problems without it
we don't have to keep building monuments
that honor the shameful practices
that created the inequality that low
status communities experience
if we use the tools of capitalism that
we have
been in a much more restorative way
we can help people in low status
communities
show that
you don't have to move out of our
neighborhoods to live in better ones
thank you
[Applause]